accueil chaleureux pour le président
jacques chirac en visite en russie où il
est arrivé cet après midi le chef de
l'état est venu pour renforcer les liens
économiques entre les deux pays
la france n'est que le 14e fournisseur
de la russie véronique sainte olive puis
encore du une mise en scène grandiose
au coeur du kremlin dans l'immense salle
saint georges les démonstrations
d'amitié son plus chaleureuse que
protocolaire jacques chirac a toujours
cru en boris eltsine il l'a soutenu dans
les moments difficiles
aujourd'hui le président de la russie
qui s'est spectaculairement remis de son
quintuple pontage veut mettre ce voyage
d'état sous le signe des bonnes
relations personnelles à moscou
l'embellie économique saute aux yeux
c'est donc le moment d'investir et c'est
bien ce que jacques chirac est venu dire
ici avec 3% de part de marché la france
est loin derrière les allemands et les
italiens
paradoxe les russes s'étonne que les
privatisations en france soit suspendu
réponse de jacques chirac à la
principale télévision russe jusqu en mon
nom personnel mignotte donc zamili mais
je crois que j'ai donné mon yade ou me
châtain chef de l'état n'a pas de
vocation à gérer gars soudain saunier 10
romain des affaires qui travaillent sur
le marché un coup de patte du président
de la république à la politique actuelle
du gouvernement
mais jacques chirac a vite été repris
par le cérémonial d'un chef d'état en
visite à l'étranger aux côtés de leurs
pères respectifs même look même rôle
claude chirac et passe yanaëlle team
symbole de cette amitié ce soir pour la
première fois boris et nine nights in
recevront leurs hôtes étrangers hors du
kremlin dans un restaurant branché des
environs de moscou
les entretiens politiques commenceront
seulement demain matin